[Music]
Robin went on vacation to find this
music what a whose idea was to write
this song s like Gary playing the
trumpet Gary you want to play along I
wouldn't even know where to
begin I think I like the other one
better now the Peru one or the the Peru
[Music]
one this is the best part right here you
can't be you can't be happy listening to
that what is This lyrics wow you got a
trumpet case and
everything join
in oh I got all of
[Music]
that
doesn't sound that bed sounds like you
could have joined the
[Laughter]
[Music]
band nice that's good it's fun to play
along see all those lessons finally
someone I could jam with yeah you just
been playing the wrong kind of
[Music]
music